[Música]
bueno yo voy a hablar de la moda feliz
para eso tengo encontraros un poco mis
antecedentes y lo que yo pienso de la
moda yo de pequeña quería ser pintora yo
tendría que haber sido arquitecta vengo
de una familia arquitectos mi padre mi
abuelo bisabuelo mi tatarabuelo todos
arquitectos
yo fui mala estudiante pues porque en
esa época había un poco de jaleo en mi
casa y bueno quizás si no hubiera habido
jaleo también hubiera sido mala
estudiante y entonces de repente pintaba
que estaba siempre dibujando y descubrí
pero tenía una educación artística
bastante importante porque mi padre fue
uno de los mejores arquitectos de su
generación en españa y también un gran
coleccionista de arte contemporáneo en
esa época ser coleccionista significaba
que conocías a los pintores que ibas a
sus estudios a sus casas y yo creo que
eso a mí me marcó completamente mi vida
entonces
luego me metí en el mundo de la moda
porque pensé que lo más importante que
te puede aportar la moda es que te hace
feliz acerté en eso porque yo creo que
es una profesión que te hace
inmensamente feliz
a unas malas tiene ropa gratis para toda
la vida que no está nada mal y entonces
bueno pues empecé con a trabajar yo he
sido muy autodidacta me choca los pocos
autodidactas que hay últimamente hay
poquísima gente en mí en mi época había
muchos más y yo quería trabajar en un
sitio pero tampoco era fácil encontrar
el buen trabajo gratis como estos niños
que están ayudándome que aquí hay
algunos de mis becarios pues pues en esa
época no te cogían para ser becario
entonces yo me inventé mi propia empresa
hice mi primer desfile con 20 años y
tenía un lenguaje muy raro para la gente
porque era un lenguaje que venía
directamente
provocado yo creo que por toda esta cosa
del arte contemporáneo que en esa época
en españa era súper desconocida
entonces si eso no hubiera sido posible
nunca
una ágata ruiz de la prada si de verdad
si yo no hubiera conocido a gente como
como tàpies como chillida como zóbel
como sempere bueno todo está toda esta
gente entonces yo empecé con la ropa y
hubo varias cosas que para mí fueron
fundamentales desde el principio primero
que la moda tenía que ser cómoda mi
primer libro se llamó la moda cómoda he
tardado casi 40 años
ver que lo más importante hoy en día la
gran revolución de la moda es que la
moda es cómoda segundo yo tengo en la
moda tenía que ser democrática porque
antiguamente la moda era sólo para la
gente muy rica que se podía vestir todos
y era es muy rico y vas muy bien vestido
o podías ir bien vestido y si no tenías
dinero pues era una catástrofe que ha
pasado que gracias a dios eso se ha
superado de una forma prodigiosa
rapidísima mágica bestial y encima
liderada por españa entonces han hecho
el fast fashion y el fast fashion hace
que casi todo el mundo pueda ir
bien vestido por poco precio y luego
otra de mis obsesiones aparte del mundo
del arte y de es el mundo de
de la ecología entonces yo creo que
ahora nos vemos en metidos en un momento
en el que es todo queremos ser
ecológicos pero como puede ser ecológico
si lo que tú estás haciendo es es
intentar que la gente te compre cuantos
más productos porque para ser
democrático tienes que hacer mucha
cantidad a un precio bajito entonces en
realidad pues estás contaminando mucho
más porque si haces pocas cosas muy
caras pues muy poco
contaminas poco si haces y si haces
muchas cosas muy baratas pues estás
ultra produciendo entonces bueno yo creo
que estamos en medio de esa gran de ese
gran fenómeno que es que una vez
democratizada la moda la tenemos que
sostenibilidad y bueno yo creo que para
ser diseñador tú tienes que tener tres
cosas importantes una cosa es su
espíritu digamos que es tu estilo y el
estilo se hace para mí bueno primero te
lo ves un poco que lo como has nacido
tus talentos yo no tengo talento para
ser médico por ejemplo porque
miedo la sangre entonces tienes que
tener un talento especial para ello y
tienes que enriquecer ese talento como
pues con la cultura con tus vivencias
con tu sensibilidad con todo lo que te
eduques es poco música yo tenía un
director general que decía que para ser
diseñador tenías que dedicar 3 horas al
día a la cultura una hora por ejemplo a
leer una obra pues al formarte
periódicos y tal y luego pues siempre
una al día pues una conferencia una
exposición un concierto una película una
ópera lo que sea no y entonces eso es tu
estilo yo tengo un estilo que a mucha
gente que no le gusta y otra gente que
le gusta mucho pero hay una cosa que es
que ha sido buena de mi estilo es que
todo el mundo lo reconoce entonces en
eso y al principio me costó quizá un
poco más porque pero yo tengo otra cosa
que me ha dado dios un poco que ha sido
una seguridad enorme en mí misma que ha
hecho que a pesar de muchas críticas hay
que ir de negro porque porque si no no
estás delgada porque si no no sé qué es
y normalmente es elegante y tal igual he
dicho tontería
y yo he seguido con mi estilo de
entonces eso hace que tú cuando insistes
mucho la gente pues te acaba por conocer
y reconocer luego hay otra cosa que es
muy muy importante que es comunicar tú
tienes que comunicar lo que sabes y para
eso tiene que estar todo el día dando la
lata por ejemplo aquí por ejemplo yo
esta mañana está en la tele ayer es que
no me acuerdo ni lo que hice ayer estuve
en una sesión de fotos toda la mañana o
sea ya pierdes más tiempo y el año
pasado hice 74 desfiles que se dice
puntos 74 desfiles en muchos sitios por
ejemplo la semana pasada desfilan en
guinea ecuatorial y mucha gente dirá y
está papac y me ha preguntado gente que
tú ven se vende en guinea ecuatorial
mohamed a primero ha sido un viaje
maravilloso uno de los más divertidos de
mi vida he aprendido muchísimo me lleva
la sorpresa de estar en un país
norteafricano donde todo el mundo habla
español donde muchísima gente para mi
gran sorpresa me conocía dónde han
estado súper adorables conmigo no ha
sido un viaje maravilloso oye y vete tú
a saber si un día vendo
nunca se sabe yo tengo muchísimas
esperanzas esperanzas en áfrica entonces
bueno pues tú tienes que estar
comunicando constantemente antes
comunicar eran de una manera y ahora es
comunicación es todo tienes que estar
pues haciendo conferencias o cohiba en
contacto con universidades con
periódicos con revistas con redes
sociales con desfiles con fashion weeks
con es infinita el tema de la
comunicación se convirtió en una cosa
infinita si eres muy tímido te da
muchísima vergüenza no quieres hablar
con nadie y no quieres ganar y te saca
una voto pues complica mucho el tema de
la comunicación y luego está un tercer
tema que para mí es el tema más difícil
de todos que es cómo produce y vende eso
o sea como la realidad de todos estos
sueños los sueños que tú piensas los
sueños que tú comunicas y los sueños que
luego la gente se tiene que comprar pero
a mí me gustaría que la gente que está
en este cuarto levantara la mano si
alguien ha tenido algo me un con un
bolígrafo un calcetín
una toalla un perfume
un cuaderno un azulejo una ropa de bebé
pues pues pues eso tú no has tenido nada
nada nada ningún baile un bolígrafo ni
neón y un mechero ni un nada nada pues
ya ya por ss pues se trata de un y una
corbata ninguna y nada nada ni unos
calcetines de hombre ni un pijama de
mujer ni nada bueno pues nada
pues eso es raro porque yo he hecho
puertas blindadas enchufes y chupetes
hecho fundas para el móvil hecho
absolutamente todo bueno entonces en el
todo ese jaleo no está mi vida metida y
con siempre con el sueño y la esperanza
de conseguir que esto se convierta en
sostenible y ahí como decía el profesor
este lo que hay es un montón de
preguntas porque nadie sabe cómo se
puede hacer eso mi pequeño consejo es
haciendo mientras sea nos mientras haya
unos listísimos jóvenes que se les
ocurra cómo hacer la moda sostenible
tenemos que intentar pues mira yap con
que usemos las cosas que tenemos ya
sería muy bueno porque mucha gente
compra y compra y luego no usa cuantas
cremas tienen las mujeres que no han
usado perfumes cuando tú te copas un
perfume lo tienes que usar del principio
hasta el final pero tener 40 frascos de
perfume que están ahí haciendo polvo hoy
y tal pues no tienes que usar y
disfrutar las cosas yo antes era como un
perrito
y cuando me regalaban una cosa en la
guardada ósea pues acá está la comida la
guardaba hasta que se me podría todo y
todo entonces ahora lo que hago es me
regala es una cosa la agro en la uso la
utilizo la celebro si no si no se la doy
a alguien y bueno pues es una tontería
pero bueno yo reciclo hasta las pestañas
postizas o sea que son pequeñas cositas
que hay que hacer pero muchas pequeñas
acciones muchas muchas muchas muchas
pueden cambiar el mundo muchísimas
gracias y ojalá que consigamos que la
moda se vuelva sostenible además de
democrática y además de artística
[Aplausos]